today on the matt walsh show we have
moved one step closer to signing women
up for the draft yet the people who have
clamored for gender equality for so long
aren't celebrating the news i wonder why
also we have our five headlines
including nancy pelosi once again
declaring herself
a devout catholic in spite of her rabid
defense of child murder and the mayor of
dc
outlaws flavored tobacco but i'm sure
we'll still be ready to throw any cop
who tries to enforce that law under the
bus
hunter biden gets ready to sell some of
his art for hundreds of thousands of
dollars we'll take a look at his
masterpieces today
are they worth all of that money we'll
uh we'll take a look and the team
formerly known as the cleveland indians
has chosen a new name
but will the new name also be offensive
we'll try to figure that out today and
so much more on the matt walsh show
[Music]
you guys hear me talk every week about
how much i love all of the
my pillow products but the great thing
about my pillow is it's not just the
pillow even though it's called my pillow
this is a this is not a one-dimensional
thing they've got
many different products and all of their
products are great so
now my pillow is changing the game with
their six-piece towel set
the set is made with usa cotton making
it extremely absorbent yet still
providing that soft feel
that you look for in a towel the set
comes with two bath two hand towels and
two wash cloths typically retailing for
109
for a limited time you can get this set
for a low price of 39.99 that's over 60
percent in savings
and um these are great towels very
comfortable and
uh and which i use and then throw
directly on the bathroom floor much to
my wife's
chagrin but they're also absorbent so
they'll suck up all the extra water that
might be on the ground there so it's a
really it's a good strategy i think
that's why i do it um always remember
all my pillow products come with a
60-day money-back guarantee so you have
nothing to lose by trying this out go to
mypillow.com and click on the radio
listener square and use promo code
dailywire
at checkout or call 800-651-1148 you'll
receive this amazing six piece towel set
for just 39.99
that's mypillow.com and click on the
radio listener square and use promo code
dailywire
again call 1-800-651-1148 and use promo
code
daily wire so let's talk
first of all about equality which is
perhaps the most destructive
myth of modern times and we'll begin at
a basic level
with children one of the basic jobs of a
parent especially when your kids are
young
is to make them understand that not
everything is equal to demand complete
equality all the time is to be
unreasonable and selfish and immature
now some parents are dumb enough or weak
enough to cater to this
childish and selfish need for equality
fairness as the kids usually call it
that's not fair and so they make sure
that that everyone gets exactly the same
amount of ice cream and each child gets
to play with the toy
for exactly the same amount of time and
if one child gets to do something
the others can do it too and on and on
and on
i've even known a family where the
living room had one especially
comfortable chair
chair with with the best angle for tv
watching
and the parents had a chart to determine
whose turn it was
to sit in the comfortable chair everyone
had to have the same amount of time
the same amount of sitting time allotted
to them it had to be exactly equal
parents who feed into the equality
demands will
end up doing many absurd things like
this
there's going to be charts and stop
watches and
various measuring devices to make sure
that everything is the same for everyone
all the time
now we don't play that game in my house
i can tell you sometimes one kid gets a
little more ice cream than the others
sometime one gets to do a fun thing that
the others don't sometimes uh you know
i'm running an errand
i'll take one of my kids with me to run
some errands i'll get them a candy bar
or something if i'm feeling generous
and then the others find out about the
candy bar and they demand to know why
they didn't get one too and when they do
i'll say well because
that's the way it worked out this time
and also i'm dead don't speak to me that
way
our kids know that we aren't setting
timers or making charts or breaking out
the measuring cups
if you want to sit in the comfortable
chair get there first claim your spot
if you're fighting over the chair i
might just take it from all of you and
sit in it myself
if you're complaining that you didn't
get enough ice cream i'll take that away
too and eat it myself
if you're whining that one of your
siblings has better toys than you or
more toys
i'll remind you that what you should be
saying is thank you dad for the toys i
have
which you paid for i'm grateful for
however many toys you decide to give me
if i had just one toy and that was it i
would still leap for joy
and sing songs of gratitude and gladness
daddy the point of parenting this way is
one my wife and i we're not wearing
black and white striped shirts we're not
referees
okay we don't have the whistle playing
referee the whole time that's not what
we're doing we have better things to do
and also again the demand for complete
equality all the time in all situations
is unreasonable childish and selfish
it's the enemy of gratitude of
generosity of love
the child who complains about another
child's superior toy
is failing to show gratitude for his own
toy while also failing to demonstrate
love for the other child he should be
happy that his sibling or his friend or
whoever
has a toy that he enjoys envy and
resentment are not the appropriate
response
and should not be encouraged he's also
being impolite and irrational
all of these reactions are incorrect
they also are understandable from a
child i was the same way as a kid all
kids are
our job as parents is to help our kids
grow in wisdom maturity and virtue
and we don't do that by supporting their
delusional desire for total fairness and
equality
we also want our kids to understand that
not only are all things not equal
but this is important too people are not
equal either
people are different have different
strengths and weaknesses and that's okay
my son is a naturally gifted athlete
he's constantly doing cartwheels and
flips and various acrobatic stunts
which will win him well-deserved praise
and applause
unless he's doing it off the coffee
table or something my daughter has
basically no athletic ability but she's
a gifted artist and she's very creative
and crafty
but my daughter will sometimes get
jealous when she hears us complimenting
her brother on his athletic ability and
her brother will sometimes get jealous
when he hears us
complimenting his sister on her latest
arts and crafts project
again we have to help them understand
that they are different
they have different skills and that's a
good thing
okay what i'm not going to say to my
daughter is no no you're just as good of
an athlete as your brother she's not
i'm not going to say to a brother no
you're just as good of an artist you're
different that's cool
that's good you want to be better at
this thing over here
practice spend more time doing it
the problem is that as is the case with
so many other lessons we teach our kids
our culture is constantly sabotaging us
undermining us we teach our children to
forget about equality and focus on
gratitude and love instead
but and hard work but the culture is
essentially the exact opposite message
sadly we live in a country now utterly
obsessed with equality and overrun with
emotionally stunted overgrown
post-adolescent children who had parents
who played referee rather than being
actual parents
i know that although i'm teaching my
kids that not everything is equal
and not everyone is equal because
everyone is different they're entering a
world which has fully invested itself
in the equality delusion they're
entering a world which has decided that
all people are the same
there are no inherent differences and
everyone should have the same outcomes
in life and have the same
responsibilities and privileges
but as already established this
obsessive focus on equality is born from
immaturity and selfishness
which means that even when equality is
granted
the people who demanded it still aren't
happy
that's the other thing you notice with
kids you start you start feeding into
the equality thing
you just end up doing it more and more
and more
because they begin to think that it's
something they're entitled to
and you see that with adults too the
more they're given this artificial
equality
the more they want it but the less
satisfied they are when they get it
and that brings us finally to this uh
reported by
the hill it says the senate armed
services committee has
approved language in its annual defense
policy bill that would require women to
register for the draft
the national defense authorization act
approved by the committee behind closed
doors on wednesday
amends the military service act to
require registration of women for
selective service according to a summary
released
on thursday now a few things we should
say right off the bat first of all
there obviously is no draft right now
and it might seem sort of far-fetched
that there will ever be
another draft again then again a war
with china
if that's where we're headed ultimately
may well require it
either way whether the draft is ever
reinstated or not it says something
about our country that women are forced
to sign up for it
and it doesn't say anything good it is
immoral and absurd and a disgrace
for a nation to draft its daughters into
combat
men are supposed to protect women from
things like that
that's the job of men in fact
men go over to fight these battles
precisely so that
the women and children don't have to
experience
the violence and the horror that's the
whole point if you're gonna just send
your daughters in anyway then what's the
point
now my daughters will certainly not be
signing up
um i would go to prison before i'd ship
them off to go fight in any war that's
for sure so that is one
law if it is signed into law that i will
happily disobey
um and i can take that position without
self-contradiction because i don't
believe that men and women are equal and
i don't believe
that they should have all the same roles
or responsibilities in society
i've been very consistent about that for
years there's nothing that could ever
make me abandon my stance on that issue
i would rather be
dead than ever affirm the insane modern
notion
that there is no fundamental difference
between men and women i would prefer
death over that that's how strongly i
feel about it
the funny thing though not surprising
is that many of the people who
supposedly feel the opposite way about
it
people who've been clamoring for
equality
who've claimed that men and women are
indeed the same
that the very terms men and women have
no meaning
many of those people if the reaction on
the internet is any indication
are not happy about this news about the
draft
in fact i haven't seen any feminist or
any champion of gender fluidity
celebrate it
forcing teenage girls to sign up for the
draft
is one of the most profound endorsements
a country can give to the notion of
gender equality
those who've been marching under the
gender equality banner should be dancing
in the streets
and yet for the most part they're not as
i said this is no surprise
we have always known that the clamoring
for equality is selective
just as it is with my kids my son might
complain that his sister got a larger
piece of cake
but he's never once complained that his
sister was given a harder chore to do
likewise feminists have called for more
female ceos and more representation in
hollywood and other
posh and fancy industries but i've never
heard any of them
worry about the fact that the vast
majority of roofers and garbage
collectors are men
that's because even the people who
believe in equality really don't believe
in it
and don't want it when they cry for
equality what they mean
always is that there is some particular
privilege
they want to be granted or benefit they
want to be given whether they've earned
it or not
the equality advocates never ask to
share in suffering
to share in duty to share and sacrifice
it turns out that even the champions of
equality know that equality
is is a is not a desirable or even
feasible goal
but even so whether they wanted the form
of equality uh that ends with women
getting drafted to die on foreign soil
far away or not they now have it
it may not be what they wanted but it's
what they asked for
and they have only themselves to thanks
to thank
so congratulations feminists you earned
it
now let's get to our five headlines
up until very recently the world had yet
to see a really successful
conservative morning podcast the content
created by the usual talking heads has
been
oversaturated with leftist propaganda
and you just can't trust it at all
but now the daily wire and the daily
wire newsroom has solved that problem
with the morning wire the morning
podcast the values your time and the
truth we're thrilled to see that our
listeners shared our appreciation of the
facts because the podcast just launched
this week
and it's already the number two podcast
on apple
and number 11 on spotify and while we're
proud of this we need to you need we
need you
to help us get the news you need to know
where it belongs
at number at number one so subscribe now
to morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcast and leave
a five star review
if you like what you hear all right
let's start i i just saw this uh
this just breaking news just came across
my desk um
cleveland's baseball team has changed
its name
so i got the story here from cnbc um it
says
cleveland's major league baseball team
is changing its name to
guardians now we know they they used to
be uh
the indians and that's we've decided
that's offensive
no one's ever explained why that's
offensive why is it offensive to say
indians
but it is now the i word can't say that
anymore
so now they are the guardians
it says the franchise announced this on
friday dropping the racially offensive
name it has been known for
as for more than a century the name
guardians
is a reference to well-known art deco
statues located on the
lorraine carnegie bridge
and which connects downtown cleveland to
the city's trendy ohio city neighborhood
those statues are known as the guardians
of traffic
so you named your team after some
statues on a bridge
of all this time thinking about it and
that's what you go with
the franchi franchise which announced
the name change in a tweet on friday
morning
had long faced pressure from activists
locally and nationally to ditch the name
indians which critics said was racist
it's been it's been the baseball's clubs
baseball club's name since 1915.
um okay so the cleveland guardians i i
think
a few issues here first being there was
no reason to change the name to begin
with
um anyone complaining about it should
have
been simply ignored but
first of all guardians before you find
out that it's based on some art deco
statues on a bridge guardians sounds
it actually sounds almost too sort of
epic and and almost
celestial makes you think of guardian
angels
you think guardians and then cleveland
guardians from cleveland there's so
there's a it's it there's an inquiry
there that that kind of doesn't make
sense
and also the name guardians might still
be offensive
i can't think of why but i'm sure i'm
sure someone will think of a reason
um i i mean right off the top of my head
it is based on statues we know that
statues
there's a lot of trauma related just to
statues many people in this country have
been have been traumatized by
many different statues um and so that
might
might bring those to light i mean think
about it the guardians based on a statue
there are there were confederate statues
so in effect
this is basically a confederate name
if you think about it
um and also guardians it's that's kind
of
a what do you think of what you think of
guardians you think of it's aggressive
it's um these are people who are armed
or guarding
it it brings to mind war and battle and
then
that also is an offensive stereotype of
native americans
that they were a warfaring people even
though they were but still
or we could go the other way and we
could say that it's offensive because it
erases native americans
guardians is a i think if you follow the
etymology of
of that word it's kind of a french anglo
word and you know in its in its
etymology
and so now we're taking native americans
and we're erasing them
it's a it's a whitewashing so there are
many different angles we could take here
to figure out why this is offensive
uh and it'll just be interesting to
figure out you know the pc mob what do
they go with i think they got three
solid options
it's still offensive of native americans
because it's a stereotype somehow
or it erases native americans or it's it
it is uh
traumatizing because it's related to
statues i think any of those are good
we'll see where they go next it'll be
fun to keep track of
all right from the daily wire all hail
mississippi
says that mississippi attorney general
lynn fitch asked the u.s supreme court
on thursday to defend
the right of the people to pass laws
that protect life and women's health
urging the court
to overturn roe v wade so this is a very
important step here
that mississippi has taken that someone
needed to take asking the court
specifically to overturn roe v wade
uh fitch wrote in a brief the court's
abortion precedents depart from a sound
understanding of the constitution
um in roe v wade this court held that
abortion as a right specially protected
by the 14th amendment and so laws
restricting it must withstand heightened
security scrutiny
this court should over overrule roe and
casey
that's what uh fitch said the brief
stated
quote row and casey are egregiously
wrong
the conclusion that abortion is a
constitutional right has no basis in
text
structure history or tradition
and that won't shock you to learn i
fully agree with that
and uh no matter where you stand on
abortion
even if you are fully in favor of it
uh you should still if you're an honest
person
i don't know if that's a that's that's
probably not a type of of person that
can exist
an honest pro-abortion advocate kind of
an oxymoron there
but if that oxymoron could exist in
reality then that would be a person
who would say i'm in favor of abortion
but
roe v wade is ridiculous it was decided
wrongly
because clearly there is nothing in the
text of the constitution
that makes any mention of abortion that
is related in any way to abortion
so it should be overturned now the
question becomes
the court as it is currently
assembled is this a court that would
overturn roe v wade and uh
i pray that they do but all i'm going to
say is do not get your hopes up
we hear in the media that this is a a
far-right court
conservative majority court it's
certainly not far right
and i don't i i wouldn't even call it
conservative majority
um how many justices how many
of all of the justices on the supreme
court how many can you can we count on
how many do we know would absolutely
vote
correctly to overturn roe v wade i think
two there's two that we know would
maybe a third
you could see possibly going that way i
don't see how you get to a majority
kavanaugh gorsuch roberts
you think they're going to come down on
on overturning roe v wade
the problem is especially roberts
kavanaugh too they they have shown um
putting aside their philosophy of law
they have shown that they
they do care about being
accepted in polite society
at the cocktail parties and so on
and if they decided to overturn roe v
wade they would be and anyone if
if this court decided that anyone on the
majority
side of that decision would be seen
as the backlash they would get is is
unimaginable i think in fact they would
they would be putting their taking their
life into their hands
you got to keep in mind to the left
abortion is their holiest and highest
sacrament
to take that away all this stuff they
say of the handmaid's tale you want to
take away a woman's
right to choose it's like enslaving
women
they really believe that they've
convinced themselves of that
and it is it is hard to fathom
predict fully the reaction if roe v wade
was overturned
even though even upon overturning roe v
wade
it wouldn't mean that abortion is now
illegal across the country
roe v wade is overturned unless there's
a constitutional amendment like a
personal amendment
which isn't going to happen simply
overturning roe v wade all that means is
that states can now make their own laws
which should have been the case
well it abortion
should be illegal across the country
um that's not going to happen
so in reality rover void is overturned
states make their own laws
and that means places like california
new york
many of the states with the highest
population centers still going to have
all the abortion you want
even so the reaction will be um demonic
we can be sure so it would require some
real moral courage and fortitude
there are two justices on the court who
i am sure have that moral courage of
fortitude
the rest i don't think so but again we
can
we can pray and we should speaking of
having no courage or moral fortitude
nancy pelosi was uh once again
given a chance to defend her support for
tax-funded abortion given the fact that
she's quote-unquote catholic
and here's what she said because it's an
issue of health
of many women in america especially
those
in lower income situations and in
different states and it is something
that has been
a priority for many of us a long time
as a devout catholic and mother of five
in six years uh i feel that god blessed
my husband
and me with our beautiful family five
children six years almost to the day
but that may not be what we should it's
not up to me to
dictate that that's what other people
should do
and it's an issue of fairness and
uh justice for poor women in in our
country
so we need we need poor women to be able
to kill their kids
we don't want more we don't want more
poor people that's that's the message
here basically
she's saying yeah i mean i can have all
these kids but
we don't want all these poor people
uh and she's a devout catholic she says
now those words do have definitions
uh the word devout let's just break this
down for a second
devout catholic who supports abortion
well what does what do these words mean
devout catholic well devout means
totally committed to a cause or belief
totally committed catholic what does
that mean
that means a member of the catholic
church so if you're a devout catholic
it means that you are totally committed
to the church uh and to the
to the uh the beliefs that are
a part of being a catholic
so i'm just wondering how can you be not
only a catholic but a devout catholic
while fundamentally rejecting the moral
authority of the church
which is what you would need to do to
support abortion
this is not a matter a catholics uh
in spite of the misunderstanding of many
people who are not catholic
catholics are not required to agree with
everything the pope says
if that were the case then i wouldn't be
catholic because i disagree with what
the pope says all the time
but when it comes to the to the church's
fundamental moral authority
official pronouncements from the church
the official position of the church it's
it's long-standing
moral teachings going back thousands of
years
when it comes to that well you're
perfectly free in america to disagree
with those but you can't call yourself a
devout catholic while you do it it
doesn't make any
sense that's it
you cannot be a devout catholic or any
kind of catholic while rejecting the
moral authority of the church because to
reject the moral of thor
and no one ever follows up on this with
her no one ever
there's never a follow-up question i'd
love to hear it
nothing would matter she would dance
around and refuse to answer it but still
i would love to hear someone say
well hang on nancy you say you're devout
catholic
the church's a position on abortion
has always been that it's intrinsically
evil
never wavering from from that for
centuries upon century
so are you saying that the church is
wrong on this fundamental moral issue
well yes you are well then why are you
catholic
if you think the church is fallible when
it comes to morals then you
have the same opinion of the church that
every non-catholic has
and you're perfectly entitled to have
that opinion but not to call yourself a
catholic while you do
just like i can't sit here and say uh
i'm uh
i disagree with the mormons about
everything fundamentally but i'm sure
i'm a mormon
that word has a meaning and this is not
the meaning
it's kind of funny too that you have
people who hate the church
despise it of no respect for it and are
not catholic themselves
and yet if you say that nancy pelosi
isn't a catholic
they take it personally they get
offended
as if you're insulting nancy pelosi
you shouldn't even see that as an insult
you hate the church you should see it as
a compliment when i say that nancy
pelosi isn't a catholic
so it doesn't make any sense at all um
all right
speaking of not making sense mayor
bowser of dc had a big announcement she
signed into law the flavored tobacco
prohibition amendment act of 2021.
here's her statement posted to twitter
yesterday
announcing it she says to attack
disparities and health outcomes and
ensure
all washingtonians no matter where they
live in our city have the same
opportunities to live long healthy lives
we must think and act broadly last week
when we broke ground on whitman walker
at st
elizabeth east on the same campus where
we are building a new full-service
hospital and down the street from uh the
future d.c health headquarters we could
feel how transformative these
investments will be
for our residents um blah blah blah we
know that black residents are
disproportionately
yeah it really said blah blah blah this
is a verbatim i'm reading it
we know that black residents are
disproportionately affected by tobacco
use and flavored tobacco including
menthol continues to have a particularly
insidious effect on our community today
we take a hugely impactful step
i hate that word impactful uh step to
reducing tobacco initiation and
addiction in washington dc
black residents are disproportionately
affected by flavored tobacco
is it how does that work exactly is it
uh you know are you saying that a black
person walks into a convenience store
and a box of uh of black and mild just
leaps off the shelf and assaults them
what you're saying is that according to
you black residents of your city
prefer this kind of tobacco and to make
the decision to buy it
that's what you're saying but they
shouldn't be allowed to make that
decision
you're you're announcing uh very
paternalistically
and so you're going to prohibit it
here's the problem though among many
laws require enforcement if you're going
to have the law
someone has to enforce enforce it
we have people who do that they're
called law enforcement officers
the same ones that you on the left want
to defund
so what this means now if you're gonna
if you're not gonna
enforce it then we might we might as
well not have the law
if you if you do want to enforce the law
then that means that police officers are
going to have to go
and start writing citations or arresting
people however the law is written
for for selling or or or using this kind
of tobacco
are are you will is this law important
enough that you're willing for someone
to potentially get shot over it
now it doesn't mean that the cops are
just gonna see someone with a black mild
a flavored you know
a philly or something flavored uh
vanilla flavored something gross like
that and
the cops are gonna show up and just
shoot the person no that's that's not
what happens but
if they show up to enforce the law and
the person they're trying to enforce it
on
resists what are they supposed to do
then
say well okay never mind hey we got to
write you a citation for this
this is illegal and they say no i'm not
i know i refuse
then cops are supposed to respond well
never mind that oh you you don't want us
to enforce the law on you well
thanks for letting us know be on your
way have a good one
once again if that's the interaction you
want then you might as well not have the
law at all
gotta think this all the way through
um if they resist and we're gonna have
the law then that means that they had
now they have to use force
and then things can spiral from there
so as i saw we say with these things you
if it's
a law if you're thinking about passing a
law
and you wouldn't want anyone potentially
getting shot over it
if it's not worth using state force
potentially violent force to enforce it
then the law should not exist and if
you're thinking to yourself well that
means a whole lot of law should not
exist well
yep if the shoe fits
all right moving on here this is from
yahoo a little bit of celebrity gossip i
don't do this very often but
i wanted to mention this nicole young
will be uh receiving a substantial
amount of money from dr dre
amid their divorce the rapper doctor not
a real doctor as real a doctor as jill
biden is anyway
a judge ordered the music mogul to pay a
young 293 thousand dollars per month
in spousal support that's 300 grand
per month more than 3.5 million a year
while it's a good chunk of change for
most people the sum is much less than
she requested
dr dre's uh now ex-wife asked for two
million dollars a month
um that he's gonna have to pay now um
okay
as far as the the specific situation
with their marriage and all that i don't
know anything about it
doesn't matter who's right and wrong
who's the bad guy who's the good guy
uh reading one of the articles i saw
that apparently allegedly he committed
infidelity but also
there was a there's a prenup and she's
saying that the prenup
he tore up the prenup at some point in
the marriage and he's saying no i didn't
and then back and forth and back and
forth
um many times in a marriage
and i think anyone as a marriage
counselor could probably attest to this
you know it's it's relatively rare in a
marriage that there's a that there's a
straightforward especially
20 years you've been married or more
there's rarely a straightforward good
guy bad guy situation
even when you mix an infidelity and all
these kinds of things
normally there's a whole lot of fault to
go around for everybody that's usually
the way it goes
there are exceptions but i will say not
knowing the situation 300 grand
a month seems excessive shall we say
child support is one thing
but spousal support for a grown woman
with no minor children to the tune of
three million dollars a year
seems absurd see the thing is
that our divorce laws don't make a lot
of sense
our whole approach to marriage our our
view of marriage makes no sense
what most people would say is that these
days if you ask most people
they'll say that marriage is a private
affair
it's a private concern and you have the
right to get divorced and cut ties with
one another and that's it right it's as
simple as that's what most people
think of marriage well the problem is
that even in a no-fault divorce
situation where you can break the
contract for literally no reason and
it's the only contract you could do that
with by the way
uh break it for no reason at all but
even there
you have to do it through the courts you
have to do it through a government
institution
and because of alimony in fact you can't
actually break it all the way
if the man is paying alimony then he is
being told that he must remain
responsible
for and to his wife after the alleged
dissolution of the marriage
it's one thing if there's a if there's a
cash settlement at the end and and he's
told by the courts well you gotta give
her five million dollars
and uh and then you guys could go your
separate ways what the courts are saying
is in perpetuity until this person dies
or marries somebody else
which they probably will never marry
someone else if it means you have to
give up 300 grand
a month right
so what the court is saying is that the
commitment that was made
actually cannot be broken it's you
cannot break it
fully anyway so my question is just
simply which is it is marriage a private
thing
nobody else's business can be entered
into and ended whenever the partners in
that
in that private arrangement decide or is
it also a
public institution in which the
commitment you make to one another
cannot be severed and potentially
remains permanent no matter what you
want to do
because right now in our culture we kind
of say well both we try to have our
divorce cake and eat it too
we want to say marriage is only private
it's just about two people loving each
other that's all it is
but then also you go get divorce you ask
the courts to to uh you know bless it
and to enforce alimony payments and
everything else
i think we have to choose a path that's
all i mean which is it
marriage is a private thing nobody
else's business
or it's a public concern courts
governments are involved alimony
lifetime support that kind of thing it
can't be both
something to think about i have my
answer but i'll let you come up with
your own
all right finally hunter biden um
reading now from the daily wire hunter
biden the son of democrat president joe
biden is reportedly expected to meet
with
prospective buyers of his high-priced
art
um a development which comes after the
white house claimed that the identities
of the buyers would be kept
a secret so this is something we
recently learned that hunter biden is
supposedly an artist
and now he's he's talking about hundreds
of thousands of dollars he's gonna be
making on this
on this artwork and that that creates
all kinds of problems
he's the son of the president you got
foreign buyers coming in giving him lots
of money
um is this just a way for for for
foreign influences
to make payoffs
under the guise of paying for artwork
these are the questions
and then you take a look at the we have
it up on the screen here here are three
pieces of artwork
and you've got one it looks like maybe a
stained glass window
designed by a first grader and then
dropped down the steps
now you got the one in the middle there
it's maybe maybe that at best is a
middle schooler's art project
that somebody dropped a hot dog on to
and then it got ketchup and mustard all
over the place
and the one on the on on the right there
that's just that looks like hunter was
printing out some kind of color
document and it got jammed in the
printer and he yanked it out
and uh and the ink smeared
that's the artwork i think he's looking
at 500 000
either for all of that or one of those
i'm not sure
i mean you tell me is this a little
suspicious
uh but then again what do i know i'm i'm
no artist
all right we do have one more thing
before we get to reading the comments i
i got to play this i almost forgot
um on a friday it just seems like a good
time for it
you guys obviously know that i'm a big
believer in aliens um
uh and and yet i'm skeptical of the
alien's
spiritual cousin which is bigfoot i've
never heard of a
bigfoot sighting that sounded especially
compelling or persuasive to me
but maybe this will be different someone
sent this to me a listener sent this to
me this is a local news report
in mississippi uh recent this is from a
couple days ago
and they're reporting on a bigfoot
sighting and let's just uh let's take a
look
and i saw some trees shaking and then i
really looked and i could see the
silhouette
of him holding trees like that and then
when he realized i saw him
he screamed at me again and that really
scared me
well we're in the mississippi river
backwater shooting the story but i
wanted to get a place that looked a
little bit more big footage so i stopped
by a couple of spots i know
on the way home on the natchez trace now
keep in mind i had just talked to a
person
who told me that he had seen a bigfoot
and that the bigfoot screamed at him
and so here's what i heard in the woods
in the urine way way back in the
distance this is
a sound
at first i didn't know what it was i
really didn't think it was a bigfoot but
i couldn't rule it out because it just
never had heard a sound like that not on
the natchez trace anyway
but fortunately at the end of one of its
last
yowls you can't hear it because it's
inaudible to the camera
but it went putt-putt put put put put
chainsaw
so that's my bigfoot experience now had
it been a real bigfoot i would have
turned into a ufo
an unidentified fleeing object back to
you guys oh
okay not a lot going down and going on a
minute
admit down there in mississippi it
appears that that that report made it
made it onto air um yeah clearly that
was a chainsaw i
never heard a sound like that before
really you've never heard a chainsaw
before it's very obviously a chainsaw
couldn't rule out a bigfoot now i think
you could probably rule out a bigfoot on
that one
and my main problem with the way that
they did this report is uh is
it is completely overshadowed i want to
hear more from the first guy
who was was face to face with a bigfoot
and the bigfoot was screaming at him and
that's the first time i've heard of
bigfoot screaming
and yet we have no
visual no video no audio except what
turns out to be a chainsaw
that's that's where the skepticism comes
in for me
and i want it to be true i want to
believe all this stuff
bigfoot aliens ghosts i'm into it
i'm ready i'm willing
[Music]
just get give me something halfway
believable and you got me
and we're not there yet all right let's
go to reading the youtube comments
this is from andrea she says matt the
bts fans who call you ugly are not only
deaf but blind as well
well andrea i won't have you speaking
about bts fans that way
okay you know i can speak of the the bts
gang
i'm not gonna have the the spg gang
uh slandering the bts gang in that way
you are banned from the show but thank
you for that compliment
um lex says you're definitely not ugly
well look i'd say i'm you know i'd say
i'm a
i'm uh i'm a solid six and a half i
would give myself that i think that's
fair
so not actively ugly it's like it's not
it's not like i'm trying to prove a
point
you see some ugly people and it's almost
you almost want to say well okay calm
down we get it
um but also not
attractive enough to compensate for my
character flaws
and so that's kind of where slightly
above average i think
you know what a six and a half is you're
six and a half on the physical
attractiveness scale
if you're usually the most attractive
person
in a dmv when you go to renew your
license
um that makes you that that puts you in
the six and a half range
so that's kind of where i'm at you know
i'm probably gonna be the most
the most handsome guy at the dmv at a
mall or something maybe i'm 70th
percentile
walking down the trendy place in a spot
in a city and
on a friday night i'm going to be more
like the 40th percentile so that's kind
of where i'm at and i'm comfortable with
that
that's that's a good range to be in um
haley says i put a mask on my
three-year-old once because he needed to
go to a doctor's visit he kept licking
it touching it rubbing his nose with it
and he had it on for maybe 15 minutes
until we got to the room how do
we expect young kids to wear them all
day more importantly why
um yeah that's why these masks get
incredibly growth gross anyone
who has any experience with young kids
knows that you put anything near
a three-year-old's mouth and it will go
in their mouth so
for example uh you're trying to wipe
your your three-year-old just had some
chocolate ice cream and you're trying to
wipe their mouth
and they'll do this weird thing where
they open their mouth and try to like
lick the napkin
as you're wiping their mouth off that's
what three-year-olds do
and now just imagine
imagine taking that that gross
saliva-covered
napkin and and putting it over their
face for seven hours
that's what we're doing here um
and uh lucas says matt do you think
demons in a spiritual realm
could be the answer to ufos i don't
because i don't see why the demons would
need to
fly around in
[Music]
vehicles of any kind or why they would
be doing it so
no that's that's not a theory that i
find particularly persuasive
and joshua says way off topic here but
matt can you please address the fact
that urinals are going extinct
it seems like more and more places are
going away from having men's and women's
restrooms in favor of all gender
restrooms
maybe tmi but i'm a dude and i don't sit
down to pee okay well
that is a sort of tmi but
yeah i'm i'm fully in favor as you know
of men and women's
restrooms um you do know though i don't
i don't want to get too graphic or
anything but
you do realize that you don't you don't
have to sit down on the regular toilet
toilets you can also there is a
there is you can also use them all
standing up just so you know i don't
know if you're aware of that
um but while i support of course the
gender segregation of
the restrooms as far as urinals go i
have to disagree with you i i think that
that is a change that i would welcome um
i think that men in the men's room we
should we should get the full stalls the
full bathroom stalls like the women have
to me this is this is one primitive
barbaric thing
it's like we're animals all standing
next to each other
no that's one thing we can leave in the
past i think
time to move forward i i i could use
that
call me um call me a diva i don't know
but i
i could use a slightly more dignified
and private restroom experience
that's just that's my opinion so if you
want to know my opinion on urinals
there it is you know if i know one woman
who isn't afraid to speak her mind it's
uh candace owens and while this
often gets her trending on twitter it's
also got her a studio here
in nashville the daily wire which you
can now come see for your own eyes
however
the catch is you have to be an
all-access member
if you are you can now be a part of the
candace show live studio audience at the
daily wire headquarters in nashville
tennessee why do we
only allow the all-access members to
come well because they are
you know they're our favorites and uh
these are very
these are very nice clean nice smelling
people that we've found
the all-access members unlike the
riffraff who are not all access
so if you want to come here to the daily
wire studios and you have to become an
all-access member yourself
if you live in nashville area have been
planning and taking a trip here now is
the time so head to dailywire.com
tickets today to pick up yours and if
you haven't
uh pre-ordered a signed copy of ben
shapiro's newest book the authoritarian
moment already then you're running out
of time it's hitting bookshelves on
tuesday july 27th
you can get your limited edition signed
book now for just 30
at dailywire.com ben that's pretty good
deal
if you ask me especially because ben
will be doing a live stream book signing
and q
a on tuesday and you can submit a
question right now
when you go to purchase your signed copy
so go do that right now the
authoritarian moment on sale
on tuesday now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
over the past week or so including today
we've discussed issues relating to
abortion a few times and that's where
the new cycle has taken us though even
apart from the new cycle
it is one of the central issues of our
time and has for that reason always been
a central concern of mine
now the focus on this topic recently has
provoked many people to leave all kinds
of comments and send me messages making
all sorts of really bad arguments
against my position
and i address some of those arguments as
presented by people on tick tock
i think that was last week but there's
one argument that i've not addressed
recently and it's perhaps
worth devoting some attention to because
many people seem to find it persuasive
at least four different people over the
last week have brought this up to me
and the argument varies a little bit
depending on who is making it but the
theme and the point is always the same
so i'll pull one of these at random in
order to respond to it here is the
argument as articulated by someone
in the comments on my show i think this
was yesterday and he wrote
quote okay thought experiment
there's a burning abortion clinic and
due to the very unusual circumstances
you find yourself in
you only have time to choose between
saving a perfectly healthy baby who's a
few weeks old or you could save a
mini-fridge
containing a thousand implanted eggs at
the very earliest stages
would you actually lose sleep over
saving the child instead of these 1 000
quote children now as i said this is a
popular argument you've probably heard
it before
sometimes it's a thousand embryos
sometimes it's 10 000 sometimes 500
sometimes there's a baby or a
five-year-old or a kid of some other age
in this case the commenter says a
thousand implanted eggs
in an abortion clinic for some reason
we'll assume he meant
embryos in an ivf clinic because
implantation
is when the egg attaches to the uterine
wall if there's a thousand of those then
there are a thousand pregnant women
and my question is why are they in a
freezer and also
if i have time to save a thousand
pregnant women why can't i save the baby
too
but this is semantics perhaps we'll just
say embryos because that's the form the
argument usually takes
and the point here is obvious if you say
that the born
child if you say that you would save the
born child over the embryos then clearly
you must be affirming that there is some
sort of inherent difference between the
born child
and the embryo which reveals supposedly
a fundamental contradiction
in your pro-life position that is unless
you take more than 10 seconds to think
about the issue
which i have so here's how i would
break it down would i save the born baby
instead of the embryos
um yes absolutely no question
does that prove that my position on
abortion is wrong or contradictory or
logically weak
no absolutely not
and i'll tell you why a few things to
consider first
we're talking about emotions here okay
the decision of who to save in a burning
building is
is a is an emotional one that you make
more than it is a moral one
the reason we're put in a burning
building for the burning building for
this hypothetical
is to get us to forfeit our moral
reasoning and adopt emotional reasoning
emotional reasoning in a burnt in a
burning building is okay
in an abortion clinic it isn't after all
my personal and emotional connection
with my own child
would lead me to save him over someone
else's
does that mean i don't recognize the
value of someone else's child or that it
would be okay for me to kill
someone else's child of course not
second point there's a really important
difference between
leaving someone in a burning building
because you can't save them
and directly killing them yourself
it is morally permissible to commit a
good act saving a child
which may indirectly lead to something
bad the embryos being destroyed
the intention in that case is to save
the child not to destroy the embryos
i'm not the one who's destroying the
embryos i didn't kill them i merely
failed to prevent them
from being killed and that's obviously a
really significant distinction it's why
if there are two people trapped in a
fire
and you run in and save only one you're
not gonna be prosecuted for murdering
the one you didn't save
if anyone's prosecuted for murder it'll
be the person who set the fire
see in abortion on the other hand the
child is being killed
um in a quote fire set by his parents
a choice is made to directly and
purposefully kill the child
it's a very different thing um
third this thought experiment if it
measures anything at all
it measures how much i personally
would value the child over the embryos
but it doesn't matter how i value them
personally it's their intrinsic
value that matters i value
my family over your family whoever you
are
i value my family over yours but your
family has the same intrinsic value
so i'm making the decision based as i
said before on emotion i can see the
child
i can hear him crying i'm looking him in
the eyes i grab him it's instinct
there's also some logic to it i don't
really know how many of the embryos are
still
uh you know viable whether they're ever
whether whether they'll ever be
implanted and given the chance to
develop
i don't know these things again this
calculation would not justify killing
the embryos under any circumstance but
it would justify my
my decision to save the child instead
maybe i can get the point across with my
own thought experiment okay
you're in a burning building there's an
85 year old
terminally ill cancer patient and a
healthy five-year-old boy
you could only save one who do you
choose wouldn't everyone
save the five-year-old even the 85 year
old
himself would probably tell you to save
the five-year-old
is that because the 85-year-old's life
has less value
does the fact that we would all
immediately choose the five-year-old
prove anything at all about the
intrinsic value of
elderly people no it speaks only to the
terrible and morbid calculations
we're forced to make when we're put in a
dire situation like this
if i had if i had a choice to save my
own child
or 100 strangers
well i've got bad news for the strangers
and the news is not that they have no
moral worth or basic rights it's just
that
i'm dead and that's my kid and i'm not
leaving him to burn
under any circumstance
so that's how you deal with that
argument but notice something about the
pro-abortion side notice how they almost
always rely on these far-fetched
hypotheticals
you're in a burning ivf clinic you're
attached by tubes to a stranger etc etc
or they rely on extremely hard cases
like rape and incest
see what the pro-abortion side never
wants to talk about is the actual
reality
of abortion in almost every case because
in actual reality almost every time
there's no fire there hasn't been any
rape
there's just the child who was conceived
through an intentional act by the
parents
and he's there now and so is the mother
and so is the abortionist and a choice
is made
that doesn't have to be made that's the
reality
so let's talk about that
but that's the last thing that anybody
on the pro-abortion side actually wants
to talk about
which is why they are today yet again of
course cancelled
and we'll leave it there for the day and
the week
and i'll talk to you next week have a
great weekend god bless
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadowsky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
john bickley here editor-in-chief of the
daily wire
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode the tokyo olympics
officially kick off
hollywood attempts a box office comeback
and the new space race begins
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know
with our show morning wire